المسافه بالعلاقات مع الولايات المتحده
اخطر على اسرائيل من اقتراب ايران من
القنبله النوويه استنتاج غير تقليدي خرج
به التقرير السنوي للمعهد الاسرائيلي
لابحاث الامن القومي حول التحديات
الاستراتيجيه امام اسرائيل
لا تتعلق باسرائيل بل داخليه امريكيه
واجتماعيه وسياسيه ستتراجع العلاقه
دراماتيكيا وسيكون هناك تباعد بين
الجانبين واضعاف الديمقراطيه قد يسهم في
ذلك
ابرز ما جاء في التقرير السنوي لمعهد
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي تراجع الدعم
الامريكي الاسرائيلي يقود مكانته اسرائيلي
اضعاف الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه سيمس
بالعلاقه مع واشنطن المشروع النووي
الايراني
يفصلها قرارها فقط عن الانطلاق نحو قنبله
نوويه حزب الله هو التهديد التقليدي
الاكبر لاسرائي الضفه الغربيه على شفا
انفجار والحرب على غزه وشيكا
في التقرير على ان ايران تهديد امني خطير
جدا والتهديد الايراني فيه الموضوع النووي
وقت الموضوع الاقليمي والملف النووي الذي
لا يعالج اسرائيل كما ينبغي ويجب تغيير
الاداء
وعلى ارضيه المعركه في اسرائيل بين
الحكومه والنظام القضائي يخلص التقرير الى
ان الاستقطاب كما التطرف داخل اسرائيل
يضعف قدراتها على مواجهه التحديات
الخارجيه مثل ايران والموضوع الفلسطيني
وبحسب المعهد الاسرائيلي للامن القومي فان
بقاء ايران طليقه اليد بالتقسيط بدون ان
تتاثر بالتهديدات العسكريه حولها الى
دولتنا على عتبه القدره النوويه
زياده حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه